- That was a look at
their new Bravo series
SWV and Xscape the Queens of R & B.
So Kandi, could you tell us
what happens on this new show?
- Well
You know, we were just
really following the journey
of two strong female
groups of the nineties
and showing you you know,
the behind the scenes of what it takes
to make a show like this happens.
So you get to follow that journey.
You get to see what happened
in our personal lives.
And then, you know,
obviously we are too strong female groups.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So you can see how sometimes, you know
we do not, not necessarily
see eye to eye, but we
figure it out.
- I think it would be a lie if y'all did,
like nobody...you know what I'm saying?
Like, especially with
that many like bold women.
- Personality.
- Like, it's like yeah personalities.
it's like if you're an
entertainer in general, like
that many artists in one place, like
nobody's gonna agree on everything.
- Yeah.
- But I love the fact that
you prove that it can happen.
Like even though we don't
have to always agree on stuff
but it can still come to fruition.
- I mean, I think that's the
the strength of being in a group, period.
It's like a lot of times
we don't necessarily agree,
but we want our fans to be happy.
So at the end of the day
we gonna figure it out
to get on that stage
and pull that show together
so that our fans can be happy.
Because we love our fans,
we love the support they give us.
Even if we go crazy backstage.
- Yeah.
- We gonna do what we gotta
do to make that show right.
- Yeah. It's more than us, you know
- [Kandi] Yeah.
it's more than the performer.
It's about them. I agree. I agree.
Well, Tiny, the idea to perform together
came from doing verses, right?
- Yes. Yes.
- This was during Covid.
- Yes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- We had one of the dopest
verses ever, I feel.
(crowd cheering)
You know it's a platform where
two different artists or writers
and they come together, producers
and they play hit for hit.
You know, they just do, it's
like a little friendly battle,
but that's what started the whole idea
of us maybe like joining and doing more,
you know on the road or a show.
- So, LaTocha, you've said that you
you were not excited about this tour.
Why is that?
- Well, in the beginning it was that
we had like kinks to iron out, right?
And so when you go through
those types of things
you never wanna bring somebody else in.
It's like having a family dinner, right?
And you're, everybody's having fun
and all a sudden we get at odds
and then you invite someone else over
and it's like they're,
that's unfair to them.
- Oh, I've been to
those awkward...No, yeah
- And that's just not what it is.
And you talked about Survivor.
This was our survivor.
(group laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- Without the bugs.
- Yeah.
- Is that hard?
Like being family and having to
like talk about stuff like that on air?
- Uh...
(group laughing)
It's a lot, you know, I mean
but this is our truth,
you know what I mean?
So we go through things
and I think that this is shed light
on other families that are looking,
siblings that are saying,
oh, they got through that
or This is how they work this out.
Survivor.
- I love Survivor.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
- That's a lot of families.
- Yes.
- So Tamika as sisters, you and LaTocha
don't always get along,
as we were just saying.
So do you feel like it's
hard for you personally to,
because I know that me and
my sister are very different.
Like she's more private than I am.
I am like, what you wanna know?
Like, you know what I'm saying?
(Tamika laughing)
- And I probably should
shut my mouth sometimes.
Like, but like, I'm like
one of those people.
I'm just a total extrovert.
Right. So is it,
is it hard for you to like
- Sometimes, Sometimes it's hard just,
not just me and my sister,
but all of us like sisters.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But it, you know, the
misconception is we're arguing,
but we just talk loud when we talk.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So don't mean we have an argument,
we're having a loud conversation.
- Yeah and even if you
do argue, that's okay.
Like I feel like if you don't
then you're never gonna have progress
and you're never gonna
own your real truth.
(laughter)
Yeah. You have to argue.
- We definitely argue.
- That's normal.
- This one here
- I'm the plus box
- This the queen of arguing.
(group laughing)
- I love it, could have been a lawyer.
So Lelee this year is the
30th anniversary of SWV,
so how have y'all managed
to get, that's amazing!
(crowd applauding)
How have you managed to stay together?
Like that's, you know what I'm saying?
Just pulling together
constantly that, look at
- Oh my God
- Your face.
- Sometimes we don't.
- Yeah.
- You know, but you know, it the, we have
such amazing fans and sometime the journey
is more important than the problem.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I think that's what
- [Kelly] Wow, well said
- that's why we're here
today as well as Xscape.
You know, we love each other,
but sometimes what sister you know,
that you don't have a fight with
you don't have a problem with.
It's normal, you know?
But we are stronger
together than we are part.
- Amen.
- And we've grown so much.
We've grown over the years.
(crowd applauding)
- And we grew up in this industry.
We were young, we were teenagers.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So our journey, we were learning lessons
as we went along
and sometimes we just
we're getting it right in the public.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, we're growing in the public,
so that's what you guys see.
- We, we've learned to
respect one another.
- Yeah.
- Cause we didn't always
respect one another
- Everybody give it up for
the women of SWV and Xscape
- (crowd cheering)